اذا هذه الصور التي تحدثنا عنها هي
احتفالات
هذه الاحتفالات لقوات الجيش السوداني
لا نعرف تحديدا المنطقه الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر اذا الزملاء
يؤكدوا لي بان هذه الصور من بورتسودان
وتاتي في اعقاب سيطره قوات الجيش السوداني
على مقر لقوات الدعم السريع نستمع الى صوت
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر امثله ابشر ابشر يا سعد ابشر
ابشر يا سعد ابشر ابشر يا سعد ابشر ابشر
يا سعد ابشر مبروك والله مبروك
مبروك
[موسيقى]
يا سعادتك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات